[Music]
Taron talks with sister and whether you
think the GMAC seen listening for a
change he may listen to her heart and as
to what he has to say and understand it
you've always loved your children more
than yourself
so one of the images to hang out there
just long enough to have it have it so
that you would think that she may change
but she's got this look on her face
where it's just like that's just who I
am
I can't help it and and Lena's in
tremendous activity in that played out
beautifully
there's such a kind of basic kid in her
still so I think she sees him in the
moment asking her to do something for
him I beg you if not for yourself and
for your child and she can't do what he
said she can it's like a kid and I
thought she can't do what he tells us to
do because that would be surrendering
for grey worm losing her is just like
there's nothing left there's just
nothing he has nothing left now she has
taught him how to be a human being like
her and Danny have nurtured him into
being human hi everyone its charlie Game
of Thrones season 8 episode 5 the
Daenerys and Cersei apocalypse is upon
us so we got to break down some of these
new previews that they've released you
look a lot of stuff that's going on with
Cersei and it seems like she feels she's
already beaten Daenerys so what is the
diabolical things that sir she could do
to possibly beat Daenerys because from
the look of Daenerys and a lot of these
previews she is completely unhinged and
as grey worm says the leader of her army
one of the most fearsome fighting forces
on the planet the unsullied he says
because they lost missandei he's
completely lost his humanity now so
everything seems like it's getting ready
to go up in flames for Team Daenerys so
if you're new to the channel be sure to
subscribe to get the game of Thrones
videos there's a new round of that HBO
now giveaway - all you have to do to
enter is be a subscriber and leave a
comment on the video you think of a
coming battle and how bad it looks like
it's going to get for both sides for
both Cersei and Daenerys and you think
about what Sansa has done recently
starting her secret plot to get rid of
Daenerys and it reminds you of something
that Littlefinger would do chaos is a
ladder there is opportunity in chaos and
it seems like sanso is trying to use
that to the advantage of the stark
family even though it seems like she's
very selfish about this I think she's
all about the stark family winning the
game of throws she clearly wants to put
Jon on the Iron Throne and even after
the episode and all those featurettes
they talked about how sonses gambit is
that she's trying to play tyrion into a
situation that will help her do that so
she told Tyrion knowing that he would
start talking to other people about it
so she's trying to create a certain
amount of chaos so to speak that will
help her accomplish her goal but that's
all separate from what's going on with
Daenerys Cersei grey worm Ascenta in
this final moment here where Daenerys
looks like she definitely wants to burn
them all so think about it this way
Daenerys has lost almost everything and
everyone she's cared about the last
couple of episodes the last season so to
speak grey worm just confirmed he has
lost everything that made him human
so that
do them together just seems like they're
getting ready to make a whole lot of
really bad decisions and you have all de
nurses advisors including John snow
seeming like they're trying to do
everything they can to pull them back
from the brink mostly daenerys because
Daenerys commands grey worm therein lies
the diabolical nature of Circe's plan to
get rid of Daenerys by getting Daenerys
to undermine herself in the worst
possible way whether or not you think
that Cersei is as smart as the show is
making her out to be you also have to
remember the Qyburn is a diabolical
genius so I think a lot of Circe's good
ideas come from things the Qyburn tells
her we'll spend the last couple of
episodes videos talking about George's
ending in what we think the show did
with the characters and how they may
have changed George's ending and what
might be similar to the ending in the
books but he's away it seems like
George's ending was always headed for a
situation like this where you have
Daenerys against Cersei for King's
Landing in the Iron Throne
so right now Daenerys forces basically
are setting up a blockade of King's
Landing cutting off Cersei supply lines
Daenerys has forces during the war
council meeting we're trying to get her
to wait a hot minute because you have
all this support coming in from around
the Seven Kingdoms and that's a really
important piece of Daenerys becoming
queen of the Seven Kingdoms
she needs the love of the people she
needs their support but she also does
need reinforcements for her army but the
reason why she didn't want to wait is
because she was worried that Cersei
would also use that time to bolster her
forces just making the inevitable final
battle take that much longer so she
wanted to hit Cersei before she could
replenish her forces but because of that
there's the idea that Daenerys is just
moving a little too fast for everything
to go the way that she wants them to go
right now Cersei has the golden company
about 20,000 troops the Lannister
soldiers the upgraded giant scorpions
lining the walls of King's Landing
wildfire in the commoners living in
King's Landing with the threat of
collateral damage remember in previous
seasons Daenerys kept saying she didn't
want to be queen of the ashes that was a
big thing during season 7 - her advisors
are also kind of reminding her of that
during season 8 the way they explained
it during episode 4 is that Daenerys and
Jon Snow lost half of their forces I
think that's more of a convenience so
that people watching the show can
understand half oh they lost half that
sounds simple
so battle of the mad Queens it seems
like they want to stack the odds 50/50
in either person's favor like it could
go either way they actually want to make
you think like Cersei does have a chance
that she could beat Daenerys but I think
a lot of her plan hinges
on Daenerys becoming more unhinged and
sir she just pushing her over the edge
into a very self-defeating place we
don't really know if wildfire can hurt
Daenerys just because it hasn't been
tested yet and on the show she's
supposed to be fireproof even though in
the books it isn't really a big thing it
was just that one time when she hatched
the Dragons the way george RR martin
explains it so just going by the show's
rules it seems like Daenerys would be at
least a little bit safe against wildfire
but you look at all these shots of
Cersei looking down in the city and you
don't see anybody walking around
remember during last week's episode
where Qyburn was talking to Cersei about
letting the citizens of King's Landing
into the Red Keep for their
quote/unquote protection our message was
well received them your people who have
heard the usurper is coming they are
grateful for your protection within the
walls of the red key very interesting
then that at the end of the episode when
Tyrion is trying to talk some sense into
Cersei and says you don't care about the
people and they don't care about you I
know you don't care about your people
then why would Cersei let them into the
red keep because that would mean that if
Daenerys were going to try and take the
red keep she would have to come through
the citizens to do it what is the most
important thing about Daenerys holding
the Iron Throne becoming queen of the
Seven Kingdoms the people have to love
her and if she plows through them on her
dragon there's no way that the people
will ever accept her as queen so I think
that Cersei is banking on this and she's
going to be trying to use wildfire to
her advantage in this situation so if
Daenerys really does wind up burning
King's Landing to the ground whether or
not she intends to do that when she's
doing all this that would be Cersei is
really easy way to get to nearest to
defeat herself so you look at all these
are the preview images you have Varys
and Jon stenosis and northerners looking
like it's Varys bring Jon Snow to
Daenerys to try and talk some sense into
her before she does something really
rash before the battle because look at
these other shots of grey worm and
Tyrion and Daenerys his throne room at
Dragonstone and this picture of Daenerys
in the map table room looking very
different than you've seen her in a long
long time
her hair's down is very unkempt giving
her an air of the Mad King but you look
at her face though she seems more like
the sad Queen in this picture list Mad
Queen more sad Queen but the reason her
hair's all unkempt like this is because
Miss Sunday isn't there to braid it for
her
Tirion here in the throne room looks
triggered like he just heard Daenerys
say something so shocking he can barely
believe it possibly further turning him
to Sansa the secret plot to get rid of
Daenerys because remember during that
conversation with Varys he really still
wanted to be team Daenerys I still
believe that she's gonna do the right
thing in Varys is just completely dead
set against it no we definitely need to
put Jon Snow on the throne and if
Daenerys becomes a problem
we will quote/unquote deal with it
remember way back during season seven
where Daenerys gave him that ultimatum
you served my brother you wanted to put
him on the Iron Throne I will burn you
if you turn against me so I definitely
think that that's Varys telling us that
he's gonna get burned sometime in the
next two episodes and I swear this if
you ever betray me I'll burn you alive
UO could this other shot of grey worm in
the throne room it seems like he's part
of this same scene where Tyrion is so
shocked and it seems like he heard the
same terrible thing that Daenerys may
have said about the upcoming battle but
because he's so detached from his
humanity now whatever WTF thinks she
said doesn't seem to face him in the
least which i think is actually a really
dangerous thing because remember way
back to season 3 when Daenerys got the
unsullied and crassness was trying to
explain them to hurt they'll do anything
you want they're basically like robots
you can use this command rod like a
joystick and they will do anything you
command anything no matter how bad it is
so if Daenerys does go full on no mercy
then grey worm in the unsullied are
really dangerous in this upcoming fight
because the Jon Snow character is so
internalized you look at some of these
other preview images of him on the
battlefield getting ready for things to
start and it's kind of hard to pick
what's going on in his brain but given
the context of the other previews it
just seems like he along with the other
people that are around Daenerys are
worried about how things are going to go
because she doesn't seem to be listening
to them it should go without saying that
I definitely think that Cersei is gonna
die in the last couple of episodes so
whether or not she's successful at her
plan to make Daenerys go fool Mad Queen
I think she's definitely going down hard
but a lot of people because Jaime is
going back to her are thinking that he
might be the person to kill her because
we're still thinking a little bit about
the valonqar prophecy there are a lot of
bigger prophecies that it seems like
thus far the show has skipped over azor
Ahai is just one of the bigger ones
people have been talking about I do
think that they'll find a way to fulfill
some of those prophecies in a very
roundabout way through the last couple
of
but not in the way that people expect it
so based on what Nikolaj coster-waldau
has said about Jamie's actions in why he
went back to Cersei it doesn't sound
like he's going back with the intent to
kill her it just seems like he wants to
be with her during this big battle time
it was his really important quote that
he had with Cersei where he said nothing
else matters except us so when he said a
long time ago I want to die in the arms
of someone I love I feel like regardless
of what he felt that person was in that
moment or how much he loved Brienne when
he was with her it feels like the show
is bending over backwards to get him
back to King's Landing so that Cersei
can be that person for him is that
estimate so Jaime
it's a fire so because the show is
trying to do a version of George's book
ending for a dream of spring I think
given whatever big WTF moments happen
that we'll spend a lot of time sort of
backtracking trying to see how the show
tried to foreshadow that but because
they're moving the plot so fast during
season eight I think it's getting a
little confusing for people to follow
especially with Daenerys like there are
a lot of Daenerys fans out there they're
like wow why is she going so full Mad
Queen so quickly this seems like she
just fell off the deep end suddenly one
way or another I think we'll know for
sure by the end of episode five what
Daenerys says ultimate fate is going to
be whether or not she comes back for the
prank or she goes full Mad Queen so let
me know do you actually think that
Daenerys will go full Mad Queen and
quote-unquote burn them all my episode 5
video will post after it airs no worries
and obviously a lot of my finale videos
will just depend on where everyone winds
up at the end of episode 5 and then also
talking a little bit more about the
prequels and then obviously we have all
the watchman's stuff that's gonna be
happening in the fall I just posted a
trailer video for that so no worries in
the giveaway I'll just leave open til I
post my finale trailer video on Monday
so while you wait for all that click
here for my Game of Thrones season 8
episode 4 video and click here for my
episode 3 video thank you so much for
watching everybody stay awesome I'll see
you guys tonight